the first time I saw Raiders of the Lost
Ark with an audience
the movie played better than I ever
imagined it could stand by the road
please
entertaining fun and Incredibly
inspiring it was a very exciting story
to tell
I was really happy it's nice why did it
have to be snakes I've remembered
exactly the cinema name and the
afternoon that I went to see the first
Indiana Jones
and it's never always being on just
excitement and danger this is the
franchise that I grew up watching
Indiana Jones movies would not exist in
people's hearts and imaginations without
Harrison Ford nobody can play Indiana
Jones
and him what do you think you're doing
man
Dad we're well out of range
we talk about what is quintessentially
India
It's a combination of feeling like it's
grounded in something historical but
then the adventures sit right on the
edge of the supernatural
I'm delighted that there still is an
interest in the character and the kinds
of stories that we tell I'm thrilled all
right here we
go back as Indiana Jones
to have a chance as a director to
collaborate with him is beyond thrilling
he's about to stumble into his last
great adventure I've been looking for
this all of my life
it takes you right back to what it is
that makes the Indie Series so unique
and so much fun
thank you